مهندس رادارات محموله بهندام النظيف
وبشخصيه عسكريه جده
الهوى تركيبه لا تجدها الا في شخص واحد هو
ادول تركي
الجاسوس الذي باع اسرار دولته بملايين
الدولارات
اثناء الحرب البارده
ولد ادولف عام
وسماه والده ادولف تيمنا بالزعيم النازي
ادولف هتلر الذي كان معجبا به لكنه لم يكن
يعلم ان النازيين سيحتلون جمهوريات
الاتحاد السوفيتي عام 1940 ما جعله محاطا
بكراهيه من زملائه في الدراسه
بعد الدراسه عمل ادولف مهندسا واختصاصا
رادار محمول جوا في معهد البحث العلمي
لهندسه الاجهزه ان اي اي بي التابعي
للمؤسسه العسكريه وفيما اعجب والده هتلر
انما ادولف مع رفض لممارسات الاتحاد
السوفيتي في عهد جوزه السلام وما عزز هذا
الكره
مع هذا النظام حيث اعدم النظام والدتها
وارسل والدها الى معسكرات العمل سيئه
الذكر قبل ان يتم تحريره اثر وفاه السلف
لكنه مات قبل عام من زواج ادولف الذي تم
في عام
عاش ادولف مع زوجته في شقه وفرتها له
الدوله بالقرب من السفاره الامريكيه ورغم
انه عميلا لصالح الدوله الا ان رغبه
النظام السوفيتي جعلته يفكر بالتجسس لصالح
الامريكان
يمضي الكثير من وقته حول منطقه السفاره
حتى صادف سياره رئيس محطه وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه وكان ذلك في يناير عام
1977 ليبدا مهمه تاريخيه كبرى جاسوسا
للولايه المتحده بالاسم الرمزي سفيره تم
تزويد وادولف بكاميرات تجسس متقدمه تصور
الاف الوثائق السريه والتقى بضابه
المخابره واحده و20 مره على مدار ست سنوات
في شوارع موسكو وقدم خارطه طريق لتسويه
وهزيمه نظامي اسلحه مهمين للسويد هما
الرادارات على الارض وردرات الطائرات
الحربيه في عام 1980 قدر سلاح الجو
الامريكي ان معلوماتي ادولف وفرت مليار
دولار من تكاليف البحث والتطوير وحدها
وادى الى اي او اعاده توجيه العديد من
برامج البحث والتطوير العسكري ومنح
الولايات المتحده ميزه لا تضاها في منافسه
الحرب البارده حولت وكاله المخابرات لحساب
ادولف المصريفي اكثر من مليونين دولار
امريكي كما حصل على مبالغ باكثر من
300,000 دولار سنويا فيما كان اجر الرئيس
الامريكي رونالد
من اهم جواسيس الحرب البارده على مر
السنين بين الف و 1979 و
1985 الا انه تم كشفه وعرض للمحاكمته هو
وزوجته حيث حكم عليه بالاعدام في الرابع
والعشرين من سبتمبر عام
فيما حكم على زوجته بالسجن ثلاث سنوات
لمساعده زوجها تم الكشف عن اعمال ادولف
لاحقا على يد الكاتب لكي ديفيد هوفمان
بكتابه جاسوس الملياردو دولار ذا بيليون
دولار سباي ليشكل مجموعه من الوثائق
السريه لمرحله مهمه من عمر الحرب البارده
بين المعسكريين الشرقي والغربي